hello one and two welcome to this video
playing international master i'm not
mistaken lotuseater and 2231 mrs. rating
um okay let's play Queens gambit him I
guess you can of course still play we
should have for Bishop g5 and things
like that but mostly it will be a
commune scam bed who is that actually
handle name very early Quincy too mm-hmm
typical recipe against early Quincy to
the c5 it's the most ambitious way to
play let's see opening up the C file
quickly if he takes on d5 I can take on
d4 yeah this looks this leads to a very
sharp position but why not
it just takes with this that's
surprising actually thought he takes on
e6 anyway we'll see I'm threatening now
95 which is very annoying move that
before Queen move screened XD form okay
night before he wants to check it but
still it sir it's comfortable queen d 1
i'll just take you four for the fork
trick he has to check me now otherwise
you lose this material should be five on
cali for tech okay is there some check
to hear
the ship yeah this is the normal move
let's play it and let's not lose on time
here he will probably go yes with this
so what now couple of interesting moves
it moves a six is a simpler the simple
one
Bishop c5 is also interesting okay I go
a six just speeding up my development Oh
actually 93 check I could have played
hmm and would have been very interesting
okay i'm happy with my position here but
93 would have been would have been very
good very very very likely very good
yeah active some active noise IAM trying
to jump into the three
hmm a 393 is not not helping much
hmm yeah a 3 a 3 sm quite annoying him I
can't let's try to do something here
with the development opening up
possibilities for possible ship c5 if he
goes um we should be 3 i'll grab me too
it's a bit risky but probably correct I
guess not be three will be will be
played at the end hmm why is taking a
very long time
kids are more more ambitious
continuation
okay now Knight takes b5 is a threat
let's get out of this keep an eye on
before keep this protected interesting
he's got one problem though and that's
called one minute 14 I'm quite clearly
ahead of the clock here okay I'm move
like f5 looks aggressive but it's
probably not a great idea let's see if I
can activate my rook here just with the
edge pawn it's something that it's not
as often underestimated you can quite
often activate with with the flank power
pushes this is a pretty decent way of
getting my look into the game
yeah 95 what was my idea for possible
Knight f3 but I'm not sure how good it
is
yeah you would probably just go Queen g3
I was thinking Bishop d6 but here's
special F for which I completely forgot
about
hmm 95 that was that it wasn't
unnecessary move really really bad know
if he takes you seven art class along
for completely this position is also
totally crazy all right i can take g7
and now time to get a gif form not sure
what this is he wants to take g7 here
okay i have b8 check as a square I'm
threatening stuff on edge too as well
okay so rook g8 maybe an end game is
very okay Jeff let's check let's check
out resigns yeah he killed himself with
the time of the time management but I
had a very good position i think around
here i just made him made a big mistake
with 95 this is a this is just a bad
move just a bad wolf i take take here
i'm very ok I'm I'm nicely developed my
rook just do something on the edge file
and yeah the engine this is giving me a
very clear advantage my memoir than one
porn yeah the at 93 which is which is a
bad miss I should have checked him
it would have been very nice he now has
to give up castling rights and then back
here and this is a very nice position
with this King running around but okay
this isn't this isn't bad either this is
actually given by the engine is banner
very interesting check yeah just just
play this ending hmm that it's not bad
at all I'm threatening both this and on
c2 with with with the text on the night
and after this this is yeah it's also
nice yeah I I was thinking just just
keep keep Queen's Own but this isn't
such a this is such a clear situation
only after a three now things get get
very murky yeah this is actually mistake
Queen g5 is better not running into this
tempo yeah Barry this was a very
difficult position and here I really
screwed up he probably should win now
rucca AC one King up and now Luke takes
d6 is winning hmm which he couldn't yeah
he didn't didn't play it mostly due to
the time but like I also didn't have
much choice and now here yeah I'm okay
again but Jan Jim yeah he this time
management cost him the game as it
happened to me also very often basically
having a winning position like he had
other guy playing a playing badly and
then I screwed it up on on time and now
it was just other way around my night he
five um was pretty bad I saw it rather
quickly after I played it but still I
took a lot of time for that and Betty
Sue's room okay thanks for watching